president biden spent his first full
week at the white house focused on
getting more americans vaccinated and
his coronavirus rescue package
passed by congress but republicans have
expressed little appetite so far for the
almost two trillion dollar deal
privately mr biden has been working the
phones to gain gop
support but his efforts come as
democrats map out a plan to pass the
measure
without them christina raffini is in our
washington bureau with the latest
christina good morning
good morning dana the biden
administration's response to kova 19
is facing both logistical and political
challenges
as it tries to flatten the curve and
boost the economy
sir it's an absolute honor to have you
here it's not going to be back
president biden visited walter reed
medical center friday and toured its
vaccination center this is actually my
first show my first shot yes sir
where soldiers rolled up their sleeves
and took defensive action
against kovid 19. one two three
but getting shots to the rest of the
country remains an uphill battle
mr biden has already invoked the defense
production act
ordering private companies to make among
other things
a special syringe that can help pull an
extra dose
from pfizer vaccine vials our work is
ongoing
with companies to ensure that we are
expediting the manufacturing of
materials to ensure that we can get 100
million shots
in the arms of americans the president
also met with treasury secretary janet
yellen about his proposed
economic relief package as new figures
show 2020 was the worst year for the
american economy
since 1946 there's not more help
many more people will lose their small
businesses the roofs over their heads
and the ability to feed their families
but the hefty price tag is already
facing opposition from republicans in
congress
utah senator mitt romney told reporters
i don't think there's a single
republican who would vote
for the 1.9 trillion dollar bill so mr
biden has been working the phones
trying to get gop backing but he says
he'll move forward with or without it
i support passing cobra relief with
support from republicans if we can get
it
but the cover relief has to pass there's
no if ands or buts
of course covet isn't the only challenge
facing the new administration
but the white house really wants to
focus on these domestic priorities at
least initially
the national security advisor was asked
yesterday what he thought were the
country's biggest security threats
top of the list he said getting our own
house in order
michelle so much on that list christina
thank you